Traductor: G H
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
A mí este señor me suena,
entiéndame no es que no sepa quién es,
este señor es mi padre,
es Primitivo Langarika.
Si les digo que me suena,
es porque a pesar
de las miles de luces y de bombillas
que vendió su tienda de
lámparas de Victoria,
para mí, más que un hombre de luz
fue un hombre sonoro,
porque mi padre, se paso media vida
persiguiendo una melodía.
(Melodía)
Cada fin de semana,
durante más de 30 años,
mi padre salía a buscar "Palomas".
Otros padres salían a cazar o a por setas
el mío iba a por palomas.
Las encontraba revolviendo
en tiendas de discos
en el rastro en Madrid, en Bayona.
Y una por una, consiguió reunir más
de mil versiones de esta canción.
Ya ven, años y años dedicados a
una colección, que empezó
en una discusión en una barra de bar
sobre cuál sería la canción
más versionada de la historia.
Una discusión que hoy en día,
resolveríamos en un minuto
con un smartphone
consultando a San Google.
De hecho Internet, tuvo mucho que ver
en las andanzas de mi padre
como coleccionista,
porque en los años 80
con un modém escacharrado
de esos que sonaban
como a teléfono viejo,
se quedó atónito al descubrir
que en el mundo había
muchos más palomistas como él,
que recopilaban versiones de la canción
y que estudiaban su historia.
Y se quedó no ya atónito,
se quedó estupefacto
cuando comprobó
que un sólo único musicólogo alemán
tenía más versiones de la "Paloma" que él.
Pam
Desde ese momento, mi padre se dedicó
a demostrar que la "Paloma"
es nuestra, que es de aquí,
de Álava, de Lanciego, de Victoria
que nos pertenece.
Refunfuñaba cada vez que se la encontraba
en una antología de tangos argentinos
o en un recopilación de canciones rusas.
Cuando un presentador la presentaba
como canción cubana por excelencia,
refunfuñaba.
Hoy aquí por su memoria y por su legado
me gustaría traerles
la historia de la canción
más cosmopolita y viajera
que puedan imaginar.
Comenzamos.
El primer palomista de la historia,
Don Sebastián de Iradier y Salaverri,
músico vasco que en 1860
compone esta melodía
más que una gran sinfonía,
fue una melodía.
Hoy hablaríamos de un hit internacional
pero en pleno siglo XIX
en unos meses está sonando
en todo el sur de Europa,
entre otras cosas,
por que el señor de Iradier y Salaverri
era profesor de música de la
emperatriz Eugenia de Montijo,
de la emperatriz de Francia.
El éxito es arrollador y desde el inicio
comienzan a aparecer
las primeras versiones
de las miles y miles que vendrían después.
Para que se hagan una idea, en 1865,
cinco años después de
ser compuesta, ya tenemos
registradas: "Palomas" en italiano
y "Palomas" en francés.
Y así anida la paloma en el sur de Europa
en Grecia, en Italia,
en Francia y en España.
La "Paloma" que nosotros conocemos,
esa "Paloma" lírica y romántica.
Para que se hagan una idea de
esa dimensión tan europea meridional
de la "Paloma"
vamos a escuchar un pequeño extracto
de una versión grabada
en griego en la escala italiana de Milán
por la profesora de canto de
María Sofía Kalogeropoúlos
que quizá suene más,
si les digo que es María Callas
y que para siempre uniría
nuestra Paloma a su Grecia natal.
(Música de la Paloma en griego)
—Esos surcos de vinilo que
andan ahí por ahí, por el sonido.—
Pero la "Paloma" no se conforma
con el éxito del sur de Europa
y decide migrar.
Para seguirla en su primer viaje
necesitamos un cuento,
un cuento de príncipes y princesas.
(Video de película en inglés
con música de l"La Paloma" de fondo)
"A Mexico" le dicen.
Reconocerán, al menos
los que peinen canas.
a una jovencísima Bette Dabys
encarnando a nuestra princesa de cuento,
a Carlota de Bélgica,
paseando junto con su enamorado
Maximiliano de Habsburgo,
el archiduque de Austria.
Se conocen en Viena en un baile,
con la canción de moda
y deciden que esa será
para siempre su canción
y también hemos oído que le dice al final,
"Nos vamos a México",
porque han sido proclamados
emperadores
del incipiente Imperio Mexicano.
Y así es como nuestra "Paloma"
cruza por primera vez el charco.
Va a México de la mano
de los emperadores y,
por supuesto, triunfa otra vez, en las
clases altas, en los bailes de palacio.
Pero a veces la historia convierte
los cuentos en pesadillas
y cinco años después de
haber arribado a Veracruz,
Maximiliano pedirá escuchar
su canción por última vez,
antes de ser asesinado
por las tropas juaristas revolucionarias.
Esta es la primera, pero no la última
guerra que librará nuestra canción.
Mientras las tropas imperiales hacen
de "La Paloma" su estandarte musical
y la tocan antes de entrar en batalla,
entre las clases populares mexicanas
comienzan a aparecer letrillas,
que ridiculizan al emperador
usando su misma melodía
y que, por supuesto, ensalzan
la figura de los héroes revolucionarios.
Y así en México aparece otra "Paloma"
distinta a la que conocemos aquí,
que para ellos es una paloma
puramente mexicana.
Es una paloma
contestataria y revolucionaria
que desde entonces y hasta nuestros días
ellos consideran una canción patriótica
y que habla de la lucha de clases.
Decenas de versiones como ésta
que escuchamos...
(Música de una versión mexicana
revolucionaria de la Paloma)
Los puros chicanos hacen
de esta su canción,
una canción que se escuchó en Chiapas
ensalzando a su comandante Marcos.
O ahora mismo está con los problemas
que hay en las fronteras
con la gente que no pueden entrar
por el gigante del norte.
Pero fíjense que si hay un país
ha hecho suya "La Paloma",
es sin duda Alemania.
En Alemania es donde
"La Paloma" ha echado raíces,
o quizá raíces no serían el mejor término
para definir lo que el pueblo alemán
siente por "La Paloma",
porque para ellos siempre será
esa canción que apareció
en sus puertos del norte
en un barco y
con el sonido de un acordeón.
Es en Alemania donde nuestra "Paloma"
ha pasado mejor tiempo y echado más raíces
y ha tenido más Palomitas.
En la actualidad podemos encontrar
centenares de versiones de "La Paloma",
desde óperas dodecafónicas
fundadas en la canción,
donde cada movimiento habla
de una parte del palomo
desde que nace el pichón hasta que muere;
hasta versiones de Hard Metal,
de grupos impronunciables
que me van a permitir no poner aquí,
Pero,créanme que existen.
Para que se hagan una idea de este idilio
entre el pueblo alemán y nuestra "Paloma",
en mayo de 2004, el ayuntamiento
de Hamburgo solicita su inclusión
en el libro "Guinness de los Récords"
como el coro más grande de la historia
por haber reunido a 88 600 personas
para cantar al unísono una sola canción,
"Die Taube", "La Paloma".
(Música de la versión de
"La Paloma" en alemán)
Ya lo ven, una "Paloma" que para nosotros
está en el Pico Gorde, en lo más alto,
hasta dónde ha llegado.
Y si "La Paloma" ha acompañado
al pueblo alemán toda su vida,
a otro pueblo lo acompañó a la muerte.
Esta documentando
por cientos de sobrevivientes
que "La Paloma" sonaba
cuando las interminables hileras de judíos
se dirigían a las cámaras de gas
en Auschwitz y Treblinka.
Pero ¿por qué los nazis alemanes
iban a utilizar su himno marinero
para matar gente,
para una marcha mortuoria?
No tiene lógica, pero la encontramos
si vemos un mapa de la época y
si recordamos la historia de amor.
Todos los campos de exterminio nazi
no se encontraban en Alemania,
todos estaban en Polonia
y Polonia formaba parte
del imperio Austro-Húngaro de Maximiliano.
Y en Austria, en Hungría y en Polonia
"La Paloma" era y es una marcha fúnebre.
Una marcha que trajeron
esos miles de soldados
desde México que venían
heridos y derrotados
y con la que enterraban
a sus muertos y
además despedían a su emperador asesinado.
Pero "La Paloma" no solo estuvo presente
en la guerra, en los campos exterminio.
También lo estuvo
en los campos de batalla.
Se da la paradoja de que "La Paloma"
en la Segunda Guerra Mundial,
en ambos frentes europeos
sonaba en francés, en italiano,
sonaba en inglés y sonaba en alemán.
Pero a veces sonaba
en frentes opuestos y a la vez.
A ver quién la cantaba
más alto durante las treguas.
Cosas de "La Paloma".
En fin, me gustaría ahora con Uds.
viajar al país que la hecho suya
al compás de una guitarra.
Y no es el nuestro, a pesar del
maravilloso arreglo para guitarra clásica
que hizo el maestro Francisco Tarrega,
que la introdujo a la música
de cámara o
el más maravilloso arreglo
del gran Paco de Lucía
que se la llevó al mundo flamenco.
En el país del que les hablo,
nuestra "Paloma" suena así.
(Música de una versión de "La Paloma")
Aloha, Hawaii, guirnaldas y "La Paloma".
¿Pero cómo es posible? Vamos a verlo.
Viajamos a Hawaii,
de la mano de un emperador
que tuvieron allá con nombre de
"Pokemón", se llama Kamekameha III,
(Risas)
Verídico. A Google.
Kamekameha III tuvo la brillante
ocurrencia de importar
decenas de miles de cabezas de ganado
que acabaron pastando a sus anchas
por las laderas de Hawaii
porque ningún hawaiano sabía
cómo manejarlas,
sólo sabían pescar.
Para enmendar este error,
Kamekameha —Palito, palito, palito;
búsquenlo en Google—,
escribe al gobierno mexicano y
le pide unos centenares de
experimentados vaqueros
para "coger al toro por los cuernos".
Y ¿qué se llevan esos vaqueros
en su viaje sólo de ida a Hawaii?
Se llevan sus monturas,
se llevan sus guitarras
y se llevan su "Paloma".
Una "Paloma" que los hawaianos
en seguida adecúan
a sus cadenciosos ritmos locales,
tumban la guitarra y la hacen la melodía
más famosa de su slide guitarra.
Esa guitarra que tocan tumbada,
a veces así como un cilindro,
deslizándola sobre el mástil.
Y así, cómo una canción
absolutamente hawaiana,
una melodía que no tiene letra,
es anónima,
que inspira al pueblo de Hawaii,
la conocería 80 años después
otro rey que visitó esas islas,
el rey del Rock and Roll.
(Música de "La Paloma"
cantada por Elvis Presley)
Todo menos el bañador es
maravilloso en esta.
(Risas)
Bueno, pues así se la encuentra Elvis,
va a Hawaii a rodar una de sus primeras
películas emblemáticas "Blue Hawaii",
la primera de las tres que rodó
en esas islas y
ahí encuentra esta melodía
como es anónima y no tiene letra
se tiene que inventar
el título, la letra y la utiliza
para crear una de sus composiciones
más personales,
su famosísima "No More" que
graba hasta en cuatro ocasiones distintas
a lo largo de su carrera musical.
Otros artistas anglosajones
de la talla de Chubby Checker,
Chuck Berry, Charlie Parker o
de Arthur Sauvé
se han encargado de subirla
a la lista de éxitos anglosajones
en diversos momentos como a ritmo
de Jazz, de Swing o Rhythm Blue.
Ya ven Uds. que hay
"Palomas" y "Palomas",
que hay versiones de versiones,
que hay "Palomas" famosísimas y
"Palomas" que nadie conoce.
Que la pueden escuchar
si van a un teatro de ópera
o si ponen una película
con la banda sonora, encuéntrenla.
O en el anuncio de televisión o
si van paseando por la calle y
hay un músico tocando un acordeón.
Son "Palomas" escritas
en decenas de idiomas,
que cuentan historias distintas
con títulos distintos
y que dependen de en qué sitio
del mapa nos situemos en el mundo,
tendrán significados
incluso contradictorios,
revolucionario, romántico,
átabicas, mortuorias.
Si tuviera más tiempo,
si no estuviesen ya haciendo señales,
les contaría porque en Cuba
es una canción cubana,
porque en Rusia la tocan
con un instrumento que se llama la fronda
y es la canción con el que hacen
el examen de ese instrumento
es como una balalaica pero para cultos,
una cuerda más tiene.
O porque en la isla de Zanziber es
una canción zanzibareña de arriba a abajo
y la utilizan en las bodas.
Mi padre se pasó, ya les digo,
toda la vida reivindicando
que "La Paloma" era de aquí,
que era nuestra,
que nos pertenecía,
reivindicando su origen
y reivindicando su autoría.
Pues yo estoy de acuerdo,
en que "La Paloma" nos pertenece.
Pero no es nuestra,
porque seamos victorianos o vascos
o españoles o alaveses.
La hacemos nuestra,
cada vez que la entonamos.
En nuestras comidas familiares y
en la sobremesa al ritmo de habanera.
Y si otros países,
si otra gente, otra cultura
quieren cantarla,
pues deberíamos enorgullecernos,
deberíamos alegrarnos
y deberíamos recordar que una paloma
es un animal viajero por definición
y que desde tiempos inmemorables
la hemos utilizado para mandarnos
mensajes de un sitio a otro.
Y el mensaje que yo ataría
a la pata de esta paloma,
sería la sencilla frase escrita
en un pentagrama
que diría lo mismo que dijo su autor
hace más de 150 años,
"Si a tu ventana llega una paloma,
trátala con cariño que es mi persona".
Gracias.
(Aplausos)